at the beginning of the week Stuart's
checking account had a balance of
negative fifteen dollars and eight cents
on Monday morning he deposited a check
for four hundred twenty six dollars and
ninety cents on Tuesday morning he
deposited another check for a hundred
dollars
how much was in Stuart's checking
account after the second deposit so
after both of these deposits right over
here so he starts off with a negative
balance so a negative balance means that
he's overdrawn his checking account he
actually owes the bank money now luckily
he's not going to put some money in his
bank account so he'll actually have a
positive balance in his checking account
so he starts off with negative fifteen
dollars and eight cents and then to that
he adds four hundred and twenty six
dollars four hundred twenty six dollars
and ninety cents and then he adds
another hundred dollars and then he adds
another hundred dollars so he started
off with negative fifteen dollars and
eight cents and then to that he adds he
adds four hundred twenty six dollars
ninety cents and a hundred dollars so
that's five hundred and twenty-six
dollars and ninety cents and so how much
is he going to have in his bank account
he started owing fifteen dollars and
eight cents and then he's going to add
five hundred twenty six dollars and
ninety cents so one way to visualize it
is if you thought think about it on a
number line if this is zero right over
here he starts off he's going to start
off at negative fifteen point zero eight
but then he's going to add five hundred
and twenty six dollars then he's going
to add so this right over here this is
fifteen point zero eight to the left
that's how much she owes and to that
he's going to add five hundred and
twenty six so I'm not drawing this to
scale but to that he is going to add
five hundred and twenty six dollars and
ninety cents so the amount that he's
going to be in the positive is going to
be five hundred twenty six dollars and
ninety cents
minus the fifteen point zero eight it's
essentially going to be this length it's
going to be this length right over here
that's how much he's going to be in the
positive and that's going to be five
twenty six ninety five twenty five
hundred twenty six dollars and ninety
cents
- $15.08 so that's going to be and then
we can even just rewrite write this so
it actually looks exactly like that
that's exactly the same thing is 500
$26.90 - - adding a negative is the same
thing as subtracting a positive - 15
0.08 and this is I will do this in
another color 526 dollars and 90 cents
- fifteen dollars and eight cents
let's see zero is less than eight let's
make that a ten and borrow from this
nine so that becomes an eight or I guess
you could say we're regrouping and now
everything up here is larger than
everything there so 10 minus 8 is 2 8
minus 0 is 8 we have our decimal 6 minus
5 is 1 2 minus 1 is 1 and then you have
5 - nothing so he is left with 511
dollars and 82 cents after his second
deposit